back with the fox news alert as russia
levels ukrainian cities vice president
kamala harris makes an interesting
mistake in a pledge to defend ukraine
listen
so i will say what i know we all say and
i will say over and over again
the united states stands firmly with the
ukrainian people in defense of the nato
alliance
now note she said in defense of the nato
alliance problem is ukraine is not in
nato so was that a mistake or on purpose
the white house even changing the
transcript which we have here to read
the united states stands firmly with the
ukrainian people and in defense of the
nato alliance and if you listen to that
and then you look here as you see we've
highlighted you can see right there that
and got added in charlie hurt what is
going on here
it's insane um you know she is really
out of her depth especially when she
goes over to europe and starts talking
about this kind of stuff she's she's
sort of unsafe at any speed obviously
propaganda is part of every war that's
why what politicians say in the middle
of war is very very important and it's
very important that they get it right
and this business of her saying one
thing and then the white house trying to
clean it up only under my further
undermines uh her credibility and you
know there's a lot of hand-wringing
about uh the us do you know people
wanting the us to do more to take an act
a more active role in in the defense of
ukraine well i can tell you a big reason
why the american people are not uh
down with that is because they simply do
not trust this administration to carry
out anything that is dangerous and when
you get things like that from somebody
like kamala harris uh it's just sort of
highlighted and underscored and makes
people lose all that much more
confidence and we were just playing
video of her standing next to the polish
president where of course she laughed
and jackie you've covered international
events with world leaders
should they have not have sent her for
this role was this a mistake it's
interesting what they choose to send her
to do what they task her with it's
usually
a lot of things that you know they don't
want to kind of do themselves and they
put her out front in these situations
that she appears to not really be ready
for and so you know you look at this and
to charlie's point you ask yourself
again i said this yesterday these are
the diplomats that are representing this
country it scares me and to rachel's
point that she made yesterday as well i
look back on this and i wish we could
rewind a little bit because i wish we
weren't here right now having to have
them make these difficult decisions i
wish they would have considered putting
sanctions in place before this got out
of control before an invasion started to
let vladimir putin know that we were
serious but they were scared they
thought that would escalate things and
it would speed up his timeline we don't
have a crystal ball to see what would
have happened if they'd play this a
different way
but the way we're watching it play out
is certainly scary for us here on the
ground especially when you're talking
about things like chemical weapons and
nuclear weapons this is not a joke
now she also made some comments speaking
ahead of the midterms and what she
should what democrats should say to
voters before the november midterms here
is a little bit of what she said rachel
i want you to listen and get your
thoughts
our task is to show people
that in many ways they got what they
ordered
right
they said this is what they wanted
they stood in line
they took time from work it was
difficult and a lot of what they
demanded they got
well i'm not sure they asked for record
inflation out of control crime and a
border that's on fire rachel but maybe
i'm wrong
no that's not what most of us voted for
but let's face it this is what the
democrats ordered and part of this goes
back to the original problem that we
talked about why is she there when we
know she's clearly not qualified and
this is a bigger question for america as
we are living in this equity and
diversity way of hiring people
the office of vice president the cabinet
of the president these are very
important jobs that should not be
relegated to people just because they
are a certain skin color or a certain
gender or meet some political identity
that is fashionable right now
what she said is that was actually very
dangerous could have led to war we need
to return to an america where um
achievement and merit a merit-based way
of achievement and that is not happening
and so it's not i don't want to single
out just kamala harris does anyone on
this panel think that lloyd austin is
the very best that we have for secretary
of defense or for that matter that our
system doesn't fire people when they
screw up like general milley imagine
being zielinski right now
these are the misfits that should have
been fired after afghanistan and now
they are leading the military response
um in this crucial time for your country
i mean this is make or break for ukraine
there we need to get back to merit-based
hiring
away from all this identity politics and
put in the very best we have amazing
people in this country hire the best i
hear you on your criticism uh across the
administration and perhaps uh defense
secretary austin's a discussion for
another day but specifically related to
harris charlie let me ask you we just
saw a retooling of her entire comms shop
because she did not handle well the
border czar job that she got they were
going to try and
reset if you will as they say here in
washington doesn't seem that that's
working
yeah and i think we're starting to see a
lot of other democrats especially in
congress who are waking up to the
polling that they're seeing for november
and of course they
they face voters this year whereas
kamala and kamala harris and joe biden
do not um and so i think we're starting
to see a real fissure between democrats
who are up for re-election and the white
house um and we're going to see i think
probably more daylight as as time goes
on but the thing that's really
frustrating about that is even though
you have uh clear evidence that the
white house is leading a disastrous
political campaign
you don't have a white house that seems
open to
changing policies you don't have a white
house that seems serious about dress
addressing things like inflation like
gas prices in any sort of uh in any sort
of rational intelligent or even-handed
kind of way
going to be a very interesting midterms
come november hang tight hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else